what's up everybody Welcome to flagrant
today we got a Boys episode listen Drake
dropped an album okay also sold out two
shows of scoa Bank Arena what that's an
amazing accomplishment [__] that is a
lot of people man congrats to to Dr
listen shout out to Drake for two shows
SC congratulations let's go man that was
that was incredible what an amazing
thing that he did man he should be very
proud of himself you know what me you
got can do that they can't and you got
to work incredibly hard a yeah you he
must have had a great team of support
around him to achieve that and an
incredible fan base that really want to
see him openers probably absolutely
incredible openers that's what I meant
by team but if you want two
compliments you know what I mean I'm
just saying talking about Drake dude
yeah it's just a drake thing well
obviously we're talking about Drake yeah
um so he absolutely killed that now the
album comes out I will say this he's
been in the top of the the music game
for 10 years okay 10 years is that at
least atast at Le for the last 5 to
seven he's got unlock
yeah the pressure of putting out a
project and every single time if it
doesn't go number one it's a failure
yeah is unbelievable and he drops a lot
and he drops a lot now Kendrick is
dropping less and he I think a it's a
different approach to an album per se
but he's dropping a lot and if it's not
number one it is a failure and everybody
is chomping at the bit to say oh he fell
off or oh he's not what used to be oh
it's not good enough Etc while also
innovating I think I understand why the
criticism comes out because nobody can
conceptualize what he's going through
nobody has empathy for what he's going
through and nobody can put themselves in
that mind state of the pressure of
having to be number one amazing
phenomenal every single time or you're a
failure and appeasing such a wide base
of fans now so mainstream now it's so I
think the knee-jerk reaction to anytime
the person who's on top puts out a
project is to find the things that you
don't like in it and I think we've seen
a lot of that right it the person who's
on the way up you're finding everything
about it that you see promis in why are
they the goat yeah he's next this is the
thing this is why he's so good look at
his flow on that you looking at you're
looking at the few good songs on that
upand comers album and not looking at
any of the misses when you're at the top
if there's two misses you're going man
but those are whack what's going on what
that you know so
I think I
wonder if he's aware of this and going
back and forth with people online simply
as a marketing tool because I don't see
him going back and forth online if he's
not dropping but now that he's dropping
he's back and forth with everybody so I
wonder if he's doing it as a marketing
tool or if he's going through the insane
vulnerability of putting out a finished
product and then you just have to wait
for the reaction music ain't comedy
comedy we go up and we Workshop jokes we
know if a joke ain't working or it is by
the time we drop our special we're aware
of it yeah music is I think I know how
to make this music and I finished making
it and I'm putting it out and [__]
fingers crossed yeah that's crazy dude
that's crazy so there's part of me that
goes okay he's just going back and forth
for marketing and then there's another
part of me it's just like nah this is
[__] vulnerable as hell mhm but we've
never seen that from him before going
back and forth yeah n that he's he's
calculated in the comments he's he's I
mean going ham on it now like he he like
Andrew Tate did this thing about how
like how can you be a man from Canada
like how can you call man yo that is
hilarious he was in the comments on that
is [__] hilarious yeah he did a whole
rant about it and Drake is in the
comments on this blog from Toronto keep
sick solid I think it's called and he
goes uh he goes uh green light what a
smiley face but also green light yeah
okay yeah
you don't think it's
happening I don't no I don't think it's
happening but what about the people that
do that kind of behavior for him I mean
he's got to have protection to be in a
rap game what to your point if it's
calculated you're a Texas boy you don't
believe in J Prince I do but I don't
think he is going to publicly say green
light and then it's a green light of
course you know what I mean no but all
of his super fans or people who want to
get in good with him I could see them
easily being like oh [__] he put that
message out there let try to get in his
now I Curry favor from uh from Drake by
handling business yeah yeah that's
usually how it works like the head dude
doesn't have to like call you up and say
yo get get you know finish that guy he
just goes man this guy's a real
inconvenience yeah just a little this gu
real frustrating yeah it would be a
shame if anything happened to him but
you got to get out to him like where is
Andrew Tate he's still in Romania I
think so on house arrest if I'm not
mistaken r d could get a Romania who
going to Romania though the Romanians he
one bar I mean he got the
czechoslovakians and the yugoslavians
ready to go he gave him one bar and I
see him posting like crazy Yugoslavia
don't even exist no
more every country that used to be part
of Yugoslavia is charged the [__] up you
know those boys don't play around yeah I
think that's who he hires to take out
Tate bro if Drake kills Andrew
Tate yeah that's hilarious
Yoo he's back to be in a feminist hero
yeah women are going to love him that's
true for all the dogs for all the
[__] bro that's what it
is whoa what a crazy do you finally put
some respect on a drake oh I'm loving
this Drake I've always said I look he's
probably the greatest rapper ever he's
just not for me cuz I'm a [__] virgin
yeah who didn't try to go out there and
[__]
everybody I just don't relate to the
music I can't live through it but I can
live through a billionaire who's like
who wants to smoke I'm gonna [__] all of
you in the comment I don't give a [__]
I'm gonna go on this guy exactly what
you that's what I would do that's
exactly what I would do I'm loving this
new
Drake okay so you like the some people
call it Petty you like Petty Drake I'm
Petty and this guy's a billionaire and
still Petty I love that now do you think
it's calculated or do you think it's I
do think it's I think he knows this is
it's good promo so it is a little
calculated he's like I want to say it
[__] them and also good promo so he
justifies the emotion of wanting to say
it there's nothing holding him back now
he's like [__] F who the [__] is this
podcaster talking [__] about me I'm
going to [__] I want to leave a comment
and then The Logical side that's like yo
that guy might not be worth it he's like
yo [__] that this is actually promo for
me so let's do win-win oh yeah let me
say whatever I want to say dance dance
dance Now's the Time like shake [__] up
cause the controversy and to your point
man when you're on top for a decade plus
it's like everybody's going to have
something to say yeah I think one thing
he has though is I realized Drake fans
are male swifties male beehive whatever
like when you're a drake stand you ride
for that [__] so hard yeah and
there another incentive to talk [__] to
people because my fans are going to put
the battery in my back yo is is is Drake
like the male Kim
Kardashian and I say that in terms of no
no no hold hold on hold on now hold on
now he got some hips on
him no I'm with you on that too Dake
hold on one second and I say that in
terms of Kim is probably the greatest
influencer in history to women right
literally has changed the way like
women's faces look around the world
right change the way their bodies have
looked like there are all emulating her
you can go to any country in the world
and there are women that kind of look
like Kim right change the way women use
makeup
everything Drake has an aesthetic that
guys are copying oh yeah yeah you see
guys that are
TR what what aesthetic you don't think
guys are trying to look like Drake No I
feel like everybody clowns him and they
say he can't dress and not clothing like
what like haircut beard haircut beard oh
maybe I just haven't noticed it I
honestly I swear to God I'm not even CA
can you look at Al's face right now I
swear to God I'm glasses and his beard
trying to look as much as he can like
Dake you mean just having a beard yeah
beards weren't cool until Nails nail
polish nail polish you trying to look
like I see what we doing you trying to
be Drake everything I did first okay
okay you trying to be Drake bro you're
right you're right well tell me what you
thought of the album from your boy bro I
was dressed like this right now yo come
on D my God you've been trying to be
Drake for the last three years Al you
went to burning man once that's you had
a religious
experience okay and then you tried to
turn into [__] Drake that is
Drake or wait a minute
Jesus
that is true so okay maybe Al disagrees
but I do think you could say that he has
had a physical influence on the way
people look like I think people are
trying to kind of emulate the Drake Look
in the way that Kim has done that for
women what other dude are people trying
to look like I don't think people trying
to look like Kendrick there was a time
where people were influenced by the way
Jay-Z not the way J dressed but the way
he told people to not dress this is
clothing more than facial whatever but I
think the biggest impact on the way
dudes look is Kanye rap wise Kanye wears
something we wear something so as much
as I want to yo I don't want to take
shots of this guy that everybody knows I
kind of hate on yeah that I have to give
to Kanye